congratulations everybody we got to
freak out about this flash finale so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet there's a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video and this is
going to be going on all summer I'll be
doing flash bonus videos every week so
I'll explain that at the end of the
video there are so many big WTF so we
had to talk about I know everybody was
like wait a minute did they kill the
black flash you can't kill the black
flash he's a cosmic entity there's
actually a pretty good explanation for
every big twist I wasn't scratching my
head too much it all made pretty good
sense and I was really surprised by ass
avatars ultimate plan but they did a
little bit of flash rebirth they wrapped
up a little bit of Mark Waid storylines
that they were doing this season there
were a lot of different things that they
were pulling from so I'll try to point
it all out as we go through top ten but
number 10 surprise surprise HR really
did use the face swapping device this
was probably one of the earliest
theories that surfaced and it was just
the simplest way to explain how Candice
Patton could stay on the shows iris and
they could keep showing us this moment
but as confusing as the timeline is what
I think we're meant to take away is that
we saw her die for real every single
time until this most recent attempt
where HR had a change of heart and
swapped them out so they provide that
little backstory where they show them
but the fact that they did this at the
beginning of the episode just let you
know from the beginning they didn't want
anybody to wonder what was happening to
iris I don't think we ever really
believed that they were going to get rid
of her so I think it's good that they
didn't beat around the bush and they
just blew right through this into the
actual plot of the episode like what are
we going to do now this avatar is trying
to become a god using Plan B so number 9
sabot our forces Sisko to help him
modify the speed bazooka into a device
that will scatter him across all of time
and space is a thin crust pizza face
best Cisco burn ever
so the real Easter Egg here is actually
for a Marvel character called molecule
man if he didn't read Secret Wars he was
a big character during that series so
Owen Reese the molecule man exists in
every single multiverse simultaneously
inside the Marvel Comics he's like one
person with many different aspects
scattered across all of reality so
that's basically what's avatars trying
to do only across all of time
so that the blastwave of the paradox
won't come wash him away but if it
wasn't clear I don't think this was his
plan B I think he always intended to do
this it's just that when he found out
that iris was still alive it upped his
timetable like holy crap the paradox
wave is coming to wash me away but
number 8 Barry decides to do the thing
that you at least expect I like the way
he sits in the Time Vault staring at the
reverse flashes costume I hated both of
them I have a feeling that hates not
going to get me across the finish line
this time so this was fairly predictable
they've been teasing that there was
going to be some sort of crazy solution
and based on all the clips that they've
been releasing it just seemed like Barry
was going to have to try and appeal this
avatar but as we learned it wasn't so
simple so I feel like they actually made
everybody happy with the way they
resolve things because the like Captain
Cold said Barry got to be the hero the
whole time because he actually tried to
cross the aisle and helps avatar out the
worst avatar tried to stab him in the
back and it wound up being a more
traditional ending villain meeting his
end but not in the way you'd expect but
number 7 it was actually really nice
seeing him inside STAR Labs remembering
everything and even though he was
putting on an act it was actually a
pretty good act like you believe him
when iris touches his face and we find
out that wasn't a deleted scene we
actually saw that weeks ago you all
probably noticed when Savatage said oh I
remember this this is where we created
the neural inhibitor to fight DeVoe in
Barry's like we what are you talking
about who's the thinker and he's like oh
you haven't gotten there yet probably
the biggest teaser that they draw for
season 4 I'll actually do a separate
video about that in another day or two
just talking about it because they've
been very clear that Devo is coming on
the show on the level of zoom
reverse-flash and now Savitt are he'll
be one of his greatest villains and his
powers involve a lot of mind-control
abilities so it'll be fun to see how
that plays out but number six Admiral
Ackbar it's a trap
sabotage sets off the philosopher's
stone in this giant Speed Force
explosion I was expecting a few more
lasting consequences like saboteur is
messing with a concentrated piece of
calcified speedforce so I figured he was
either going to try and poison the Speed
Force or cut Barry off from it or
something really terrible on par with
the Speed Force storm at the end of the
episode would happen but it seems like
the TV show was really only using it as
speedforce dirty bomb - just blow up
everybody it wasn't any grand plan
beyond that and I'll talk about speed
for science at the end of the video -
because there's a lot of big questions
based on the way they ended the episode
number five the Gypsy saved so glad she
came back she vibes Cisco from across
the multiverse because they're connected
as she says they have a lot of funny
dialogue I love their scenes together
Jessica Camacho the actress that plays
her is great I hope she always comes
back on the flash but I don't think that
she's going to be a series regular next
year just because it'd be a duplication
of powers so number four this is so much
fun saboteur and Caitlin destroy the
black flash is they prepare to scatter
savat are across time space so for those
of you that are wondering you're like
wait a minute hey they can't destroy the
black flash this is such a big deal you
have to have a black flash and yes you
do have to have a black flash when she
says goodbye hunter as in goodbye hunter
zolomon remember this zoom became the
black flash so what they're saying is is
that he's dead but that just means that
someone else is going to have to take
his place so we'll meet a new black
flash some time during season 4 now the
big question is who will it be Barry
Allen was the black flash for a very
brief period thanks to the efforts of
eobard thawne we haven't seen the
reverse flash comeback yet he could
always show up as the black flash
briefly but he's such an important
character that I don't think that they
would do that to him for too long like
you want to have the reverse flash do
reverse flash things and once you become
the black flash you're more like a Speed
Force dog that just chases down
aberrations
but either way yes the black flash is
gone he will come back but it'll be a
different speedster that's taken up the
mantle so Caitlin starts scattering
savat are across the speedforce in
number 3 out pops jay garrick surprise
[ __ ] Cisco mess with a gun in an
unlocked the speedforce prison so Jay
Garrick was able to run out I've been
waiting to do that such a great twist I
was just waiting for him to come back he
always gets to come back with really
badass saves like that but then it
becomes this big battle royale team
flash vs. team zoom Cisco saved Caitlin
and she helps save him from sabotage so
eventually the big twist though is that
iris is the one to finally defeats
avatar but not before a whole bunch of
fancy footwork
with Grant Gustin in that suit so I know
everybody's like why did he destroy
sabotage suit first of all it was just
badass watching him phase into that and
seeing the suit turn red and crackling
with Speed Force energy like sabotage
said you kill me you become me
so obviously the flash always stays a
hero like Captain Cold said so he
vibrates the suit apart and that's the
end of it but the big change from the
comics is that the future flash and
Savitt are which are two different
characters they kind of combined them
into one for the TV show the mark Wade's
avatar storyline it's called dead heat
he actually wanted to become one with
the Speed Force which is kind of like
what's avatars plan is like become this
all-powerful god so at the time Wally
West was the only version of the flash
Barry Allen has still been dead in the
comics for a while he just runs sabotage
into the Speed Force because he can't
get into it by himself and he gets
trapped there later shows up during the
first flash rebirth which was the formal
return of Barry Allen like you see him
exit the Speed Force I'm free in this
panel and then he just disintegrates
into nothing that's almost immediately
it was really funny come back for the
character but in the comics the future
flash has a more heroic ending he
actually tries to help out a little bit
he's like a less crazy version of future
Barry but he ends up getting vaporized
too so it was sort of an amalgam of the
Sabbat are ending in the future flash
ending in the comics with a slightly
more villainous ending saboteur was a
real villain in the comics the future
flash was only a villain for a little
while until he came around and was
trying to help things but number two
they bury HR I know everybody was
questioning me all the back half of the
season about this special funeral scene
who is that in the casket we're all
wondering so now we learned that it's HR
making that season four synopsis that
they've released somewhat of a live they
actually named HR as part of the cast
for season four so now I don't think
that Tom Cavanagh is leaving the show so
what'll probably happen now is when they
come back it'll be earth to Harrison
wells
and then they'll decide whether or not
they're going to keep him around or
it'll be a different version of Harrison
wells but Tom Cavanagh is still a series
regular as far as we know so regardless
of which version of him it's going to be
he's not going anywhere
I like that John Lennon quote and if
you're wondering about the Caitlin
ending - she's still a series regular
danielle Panabaker isn't going anywhere
but she just saying that she's not going
to come rejoin team flash I need to find
out what's going on on my own so what
will probably happen is is it she'll
still get to be a little bit bad but she
won't be full-blown evil so she'll still
have her powers but this is what her
eyes will look like she won't wear
special contacts anymore she actually
said that they're really hard to see and
when they're filming scenes so this is a
bit of a compromise for the character
and when you see her Hulk out
her eyes will probably go blue again so
that can be like a fun way for them to
show her reacting to stuff like oh crap
she's getting ready to go off like an
ice bomb but a lot of the scenes that
she's going to have next season have a
lot to do with who I think the villains
are going to be and that's a largely
rogue base until de veau surfaces and
become sort of the overarching villain
so think about how Captain Cold is a
villain but he also helps Barry out
every once in a while
that'll probably be how Caitlin's
character works where she'll still be
kind of bad trying to figure things out
but she'll still come back and help out
the people at STAR Labs every once in a
while so of course number one big ending
Barry enters the Speed Force what does
this mean oh my god they're doing the
Speed Force storm from flash rebirth
does this mean there's going to be more
new metas so there's a bunch of things
to explain if you haven't read the
comics one flash rebirth in the Speed
Force storm if you haven't read the
Godspeed arc from the flash comics that
happened last summer what happened is
there was just a freak Speed Force storm
that created a bunch of new speedsters
Barry on has to learn to train them one
of them wound up being super evil and
became the god speed character so
because they said that there's not going
to be another big bad speedster next
season I don't think that they're going
to do that part of it
but they always do this thing on the
flash where the big disaster of the
finale surfaces all the villains of the
next season so in a season one we got
the big wormhole in the sky that's where
the breaches came from all the villains
from earth to the season three twist was
flashpoint you got all the flashpoint
husks now we have giant speed for storm
probably going to create a bunch of new
metas for next season and that'll be
part of the conflict especially in the
first episode where we'll probably get
Barry back but we'll get this backstory
over the course of the three months of
the break where we see what Wally did
trying to be
main flash while Barry wasn't around
don't worry the city will still have a
flash and now we have a speed force
scientist so how do we get Barry back
from the Speed Force there's so many
ways to do it but you need to study the
Speed Force to understand how it works
and that's what Traci brand's character
is all about so in this moment whether
they're like oh my god you have to go
into the prison none of them really
understand the mechanics of how that
worked because the prison itself wasn't
created till very far in the future so
they don't know what's going on yet but
we'll probably start pushing into the
mythology of the Speed Force even deeper
in the science of it in season 4 so my
next flash video will be my season 4
predictions that'll post at least by
Thursday but I'll do like a teaser video
where sabotage talking about devote oh
you haven't got there yet well like I
said I'm going to be doing bonus videos
for the flash as well as the comics all
summer long it'll be at least like two
videos a week so just let me know what
you want those to be about leave all
your requests they'll still be blast
ring giveaways and all of them so I'll
say congratulations to the latest winter
white canary please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details while you wait
for everything you can click here for
all my flash videos and you can click
here for a brand new game of Thrones
promo thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you